Hey c'est là première fois que je prends un avion où il y'a si peu de turbulence.
C'est heu génial !
C'est normal on n'a pas décollé encore
*AH*
C'est quand même plus grand que chez Shopi
Alors avant de faire de la plongée, on doit remplir un questionnaire de santé
Pour voir si on est pas un peu .... Chelou
'Avez-vous des problèmes mentaux ?'
Bon bah oui hein !
'YES' !
Je suis habillé en combinaison de plongée, plutôt stylée
...sauf un petit détail
Les chaussures nulles du plongeur de Dunkerque !
On va faire de la plongée, et on a totalement peur
C'est la de la plongée avec de la truite, ou...
c'est pas des truites, c'est des énormes skarks !!
Oh my god !
D'abord je me remets de mes émotions parce que là je tombe dans les pommes
Je tremble car j'ai eu trop peur
J'ai euh.. une crise de je sais pas comment ça s'appelle...
Tétanie
Y'a des millions de poisson qui aimaient bien passer à un millimètre de mon corps !
Euh.. J'avais envie de leur dire ben..
"Ne me touche pas ! Tu es dégueulasse !
J'suis pas ton pote ok ??"
Vas y prends du père dodu là !
Ah, par contre ici c'est pas du père dodu hein
C'est du père "Al Baker"
C'est son cousin du bled
Beh ! C'est génial !
Un soda moisi
En Arabe y'a pas le "P"
C'est à dire ça par exemple ça se dit
"Bringels"
Je sais lire l'Arabe hein..
Sérieux ?
"Nutella"
On fait nos courses la nuit keskia ??
On est des junkies
Dubaï c'est vraiment la ville de tous les records
Là par exemple le plus petit terrain de foot du monde !
Allez Zlatan !
Ca c'est la fameuse île en forme de palmier
Et tout ce qu'on voit ici
A 100% été construit par l'homme
Et Dubaï est une ville qui est en perpétuelle construction
Là on voit encore tous les chantiers
Jusqu'à ce que cette ville ressemble à Gotham City !
Très bons ces petits fruits !
Norman tu veux une banane une orange ?
Parce qu'a ce moment là le mec ! Il lui dit "c'est un lâcher de SALOPES !!"
Qui veut faire un pique-nique sur le short de Titouche ?
Moi !
Ramène le saucisson
Le maitre nageur le moins utile du monde
Il surveille 2 personnes qui ont pied
Là y a le truc du sarcophage, je le fais pas parce que c'est n'importe quoi
Par contre je vais juste rentrer dedans pour prendre une petite photo
Juste un petit selfie !
Nan t'inquiète c'est bon..
Neuf, dix..
Ca existe pas cet exercice Norman hein..
Donc Norman pense que ceci
N'est pas un piment mais un poivron
Nan mais c'est par parce que ça à la forme d'un piment que c'est forcément un piment
Je te jure que c'est un piment ! Goûte !
Croque !
Ici tu peux acheter des petits muslims pour endormir ton enfant
Y'a des petits chameaux aussi
Ah forcément Arabe = Chameau
Et du petit couscous, allez excellent !
Ca c'est la tour "Burj Khalifa"
La tour la plus haute du monde
Elle fait environ 3 fois la taille de la tour Eiffel
Soit 600 000 fois la taille de Hugo tout seul
Ca va ?
J'suis grillé
Tu viens perturber mon plan, j'te filme ?
J'suis désolée
Mon frère est un grand fan et d'ailleurs il a..
T'as la pression là hein ?
Ouais, il a..
Elle a totalement la pression quand elle parle
Il a un blog sur youtube aussi..
Un blog sur youtube ça ne veut rien dire
Pardon, un...
Une chaine !
J'suis en train de suer au maximum
Comme une sorte d'être dégueulasse
Ca te dérange pas ?
En France quand tu fais de la pêche au canard dans les fêtes foraines ben, tu les pêches, c'est mignon
C'est poétique
A Dubaï tu leur pète la gueule !
Trop bizarre ce prospectus,
"On fait un accident lol c'est génial !"
J'profite du fait d’être à l'étranger pour manger enfin un peu sainement
Une patinoire dans un centre commercial
C'est un truc de ouf
Le mec il veut rester parce qu'il doit finir de peter des bulles
Attends
T'es jaloux
Tank c'est tortue
Putain merde..
Nan parce que je pensais à Tortank n'importe quoi..
C'est un pokémon !
Ici quand j'essaye de parler en anglais
mon accent n'a aucun sens
tout est mélangé
C'est donc un restaurant aquarium
Tu manges en voyant les poissons
C'est hyper classe
Est ce que si jamais là j'te dis,
J'ai envie de manger
lui
Pas lui hein !
Euh.. Le poisson !
A la vôtre !
Aujourd'hui c'est journée désert, on prend tous le 4x4 et on va dans les dunes
Mais en chemin on s'arrête quelques minutes
pour que certains aillent faire leur prière,
leur Salat comme on dit
Et ouais ! Pays Musulman ma gueule !
Et pendant que je fais ce plan,
une famille..
Wow !
C’était un Arabe surprise !
Hey.. Faut qu'on arrête la caisse..
J'suis pas bien du tout
Il vomit
Ah, c'est dégueulasse !
A chaque activité est associé,
un traumatisme de mon corps
Hey Youtube !
On est dans le désert !
Ca fait 45 minutes qu'on marche dans le désert...
T'es pas crédible avec tous les touristes derrière
C'est clair !
Aujourd'hui, on va faire du Ray-Feeding
Tu penses que c'est une activité totalement extrême
Qu'on va faire les X-Games
Euh, non, c'est juste nourrir des raies...
Les poissons qui sont plats...
C'est de pas donner ça,
Sinon, elle te mange ton index !
Ah !
Elle, elle arrive !
Je me casse
Ah !
Don't approach me !
Oh, putain ! Bouge pas ! Bouge pas !
Allez, viens lui donner !
Je lui ai déjà donné deux fois !
Je caresse les raies
Moi, je suis en fusion avec les raies!
Tu te casses ?
Et ça, c'est votre moyen de transport ?
Habituel... C'est normal !
J'aime pas trop ça, moi !
Je préfère le scooter.
Y a vraiment des boutiques attrape-touristes où ils vendent n'importe quoi.
Mon gars, je t'ai ramené une cuillère de Dubaï !
Plaquée or, tu m'en diras des nouvelles !
Salam Halekoum, les frères et les soeurs !
Salam Halekoum !
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo !
En direct de Dubaï, aux Emirats Arabes Unis !
Je vous ai emporté avec moi, comme je peux
Avec ma caméra
J'espère que vous avez kiffé un petit peu aussi !
N'hésitez pas à mettre un petit pouce en l'air
Ok, pour le prochain voyage
On se retrouve à Istres
On va faire une putain de vidéo vlog à Istres
Porchain voyage: Melun !
Soyez présent !
C'est la même vanne !
Norman fait des vidéos !
Abonnez-vous !
J'ai aussi vu parfois des profils de meufs
Avec écrit en bibliographie:
"Je recherche uniquement des amis"
T'es sérieuse, là ?
Tu cherches des amis ?
Mais c'est pas sur Tinder que tu aurais dû t'inscrire !
C'est à une colonie de vacances !
C'est quoi ces gens qui ne comprennent pas le principe
d'une application de rencontre ?
Bah voilà, moi je suis inscrite sur Tinder
Mais uniquement pour me faire des amis !
Et toi ?